OHAHAHA
OHOHOHO
You thought I was
DONE
with this GAME?
think again motherfuckAAAA.
I'm back
You thought I was actually angry?!
from a video game?
What do you think, I'm some child?(Yes, actually)
do I look like a child to you?
EASY
Anyone who hasn't beaten this game.
Is a goddamn
dare I say it
CaSUAL.
look at this jump
look at this jump.
Oh my god
Ohhhh-ohhhh-oh
I'm enjoying myself
Having a good time
with laughter and friends(what friends) and...
making, uh, happy times
happy memories
Wait, why am I going this way?
I don't--I'm not even supposed to go this way.
Oh my god.
Whatever
Oh Wow
look at that
look at that everybody
turns out.
I'm the best player alive
how'bout'dat?
oh no!
Okay, we're good
this bit is so fucking stupid
Seriously, thi--this bit is just dumb
It doesn't even make any--sense
Oh good
look at that
good
Good
GOOOOODDDDD!
Come on!
Suck a dick.
SUCK THE DICK!!
SUCK
the dick
SUCK IT.
SUCK--
THAAAA!
AHHHHG
You're so annoying
STOP
STAAAAP
STAAAHAAHA
AHHHHHHH
GO UP THERE
This bit just sucks,
it fucking sucks.
Thank you,
MY GAAH!
new strat everybody,
new strat
it's like you do one thing
Congrats
now you have to do 500 other things.
What are you...?
my god...
I think I know what to do.
No.
No,
that's not where you were supposed to do
Oh Good, goo--
oh good.
Oh good. (x2)
You're here now.
Oh good.
That's good.
That's fuckin' great!
Okay, we're back everybody
how about that
that...isn't that great for everybody?
Oh, wow.
Oh!
Oh
No no no
we're fine
God damn
that's a lot easier.
Oh my god.
That was close
No!
Oh
HUUUUGGH
Baby steps?
Baby steps.
We're taking baby steps everybody.
There's nothing wrong with baby steps
It's nice and safe
everyone loves baby steps.
We all have to do baby steps.
Oh, look
oh look
we're back here
(laughing like a mad man)
* INHALE *
Mr. Orange
Pleased to make your acquaintance.
FUCK OFF.
Oh God.
What did I just do?
Bye-bye!
* GUD MUSIC *
Okay,
alright.
Come on.
COME ON!
Easy! (ha I think not)
WHAT ARE YOU DOING??????!!!!!!!!
OOOHHHAAAAAAAAAAAHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHH
WHAT?
*more extremely sexual moans*
you what...
All the way
all of the way
To the very beginning huh?
Can this tree
suck a dick?
like what is happening?
Whatever
You know?
Whatever!
whatever.
Whatever.
Okay?
Do I look like I care?
I don't fuckin' care
Listen, I just fell away from the top of the map to the bottom.
Don't play this music
Okay?
Play some Lincoln park or Evanescence.
I need some real emo shit
OH Look at that
You think I care?
This game is easy.
I jumped off on purpose.
I wanted the challenge.
Do you think I
FUCKING CARE?
DO YOU THINK?
Oh God.
Oh God
not it.
No.
Stop falling down you fucker
* Musical interlude! *
Oh look we're back here
by the fucking lights
Like this bit isn't annoying at all.
Fuckin' have to squeeze a dick to get through
Look, I'm breaking the god damn hammer.
Can you
FUCKING
fuck off
There we go there we go finally Jesus Christ okay? OH LOOK we're back here everybody OOHHHHHHHHH
The reason I click 500 times is just
cuz I changed the DPI
on the fucking mouse
Because I get stuck in these fucking places
so I have to
it says more about your fucking game than me alright
It doesn't fucking...
suck a dick, man
I hate this bit
it's so annoying
it's just annoying
it's just pure luck if you get through
I can't turn my mouse that fast
fuck off then
There we go
there we go
finally Jesus Christ
okay?
OH LOOK
we're back here everybody
OOHHHHHHHHH
isn't that just great
My favourite bit of the game.
I'm coming back.
I'm coming back
I'm coming back, baby.
I'm coming up, (sings: I'm coming out-DIana Ross)
I want the world to know.
I'm coming back
Oh loot at that
look who's back everybody,
(puberty Felix) IIIIITTTSSS me
POOdiepie
You thought I would give up
Didn't ya?
NEVER GIVE UP
Excuse me
I thought I muted you
Voiceover volume zero
I don't need your Nietzsche sputes
There we go,
oh look who's back baby,
I'm back
and I'm back for BLoOd
I'm back for blood
No no no
phew,
Jesus Christ,
what's wrong with you?
if your dick didn't get so FuCkINg hard
This wouldn't be so hard
oh my god
oh I did it
okay
that works, too I guess.
the fuck did I do?
I'm coming
I'm back, baby.
You thought I was gonna quit did ya????
HA
HAAAAA
ya thought I was gonna quit did ya????
quittin' is for losers.
Do I look
like a look...
aye aye aye ay ay
Relax
ReLAx
look who's back BABY.
OOOOHHHHH
look who's back Mr. Orange
Look who is back, baby
EASY
That was so easy
my god.
I'm gonna climb this mountain
Thank you very much.
All right
We cool????????
Now don't push me down
like you did last time please,
okay, okay?
okay okay okay okay
I'm just trying to get the damn right angle.
I don't know how the heck I went down last time
Like that bit so easy
here's when the hard bit comes
EEAAASSSSSYYYYYY
EEEEEAAAASSYYYYYYYY
(creepy chuckles)
*inhales*
NO
hold...
hold on
HOLD ON (voice breaks) everyone
Okay, okay, okayyyyy.
It's o-kayyy
its okay
its okay everybadyyy
ITS OKAAY
OKAYY HA
(say wut?)
ahhhhhh
fine
(extreme rapey voice)
EASY
no
fuck
honestly,
I'm fine
I'm doing great
oh, oh that's Great
no no no no no
thats JUST want I wanted
oh no no,
keep falling, keep falling
(high pitched) oh no thats great
*claps sarcastically* oh
oh look at dat
oh look at that
you- oh my god
ohooooo
STAAHHHHPPPPP
oh now I've gotta do the lights again?
I hate the fucking lights
ohhhh
Okay
(crazy laughter) HAHAHAHA
It's not fucking funny at this point.